Hablemos un poco sobre las fuerzas ion dipolo.
Pero antes de pensar en cómo los iones y
dipolos podrían interactuar, recordemos cuál es la
diferencia entre iones y dipolos. Los invito a que
pausen el video e intenten refrescar su propia
memoria antes de que lo recordemos juntos. Muy
bien, ahora pensemos primero en iones. Los iones
son átomos o moléculas que tienen una carga neta,
entonces, por ejemplo, cuando el cloro gana
un electrón y se convierte en el ion cloruro,
es un ion porque ahora tiene una carga negativa
neta. De manera similar, cuando el sodio pierde
un electrón, ahora tiene una carga positiva
neta, entonces este es el ión sodio. ¿Cuál es
la diferencia entre eso y un dipolo? Bueno, en
general, cuando hablamos de dipolos no estamos
hablando de algo que necesariamente tiene una
carga neta, estamos hablando de algo donde la
carga está separada en diferentes extremos de
la molécula, que tiene un extremo parcialmente
positivo y tiene un extremo negativo parcial,
que hay un momento dipolar molecular. Y un buen
ejemplo de una molécula que es un dipolo o tiene
un momento dipolar a nivel molecular es el agua.
El agua es una molécula muy polar. Hemos hablado
de esto muchas veces: tenemos el oxígeno, que es
bastante electronegativo, unido covalentemente
a 2 hidrógenos, y esos son realmente enlaces
covalentes polares porque el oxígeno es mucho
más electronegativo y acapara los electrones,
es egoísta con los electrones. Y dado que
los electrones pasan más tiempo alrededor
del oxígeno que alrededor del hidrógeno tienen
una carga negativa parcial en este extremo de
la molécula y hay cargas positivas parciales en
el otro extremo de la molécula. Describimos esto
cuando hablamos de enlaces de hidrógeno, donde
el extremo negativo parcial de una molécula de
agua sería atraído al extremo positivo parcial de
otra molécula de agua. Pero como hemos mencionado,
los enlaces de hidrógeno, que son una fuerza
intermolecular, son sólo un caso especial
de fuerzas dipolo dipolo. Las cosas que pueden
formar enlaces de hidrógeno sólo tienen un momento
dipolar muy fuerte porque tenemos el hidrógeno
unido a un oxígeno, un nitrógeno y un flúor, que
es bastante electronegativo. Entonces, ahora que
recordamos la diferencia entre iones y dipolos,
¿cómo podrían interactuar? Bueno, pueden adivinar
que las fuerzas de Coulomb están en juego:
el extremo negativo parcial de un dipolo sería
atraído por un ion cargado positivamente. Y he
ordenado previamente estas moléculas de agua para
que tengan el extremo negativo parcial orientado
hacia este ion positivo de sodio. Y, entonces, lo
que estoy dibujando aquí son fuerzas ion dipolo.
Del mismo modo, si hay un anión cloruro o un
ion negativo, entonces los extremos parcialmente
positivos de los dipolos serán atraídos, por lo
que el agua podría organizarse de esta manera:
donde termina el positivo parcial, el que termina
con el hidrógeno, está frente al cloro. Y esta es
una de las razones por las que es tan fácil
disolver el cloruro de sodio, disolver la sal
de mesa en agua. Estos iones pueden separarse y
ser atraídos por las moléculas de agua que son
polares, que tienen dipolos moleculares. Ahora,
si tuviera que preguntarles ¿qué evitará la fuerza
de las fuerzas ión dipolo? Piensen en eso, pausen
el video. ¿Qué creen que es lo importante? Bueno,
como pueden imaginar, estas son las fuerzas de
Coulomb, entonces, la fuerza de las cargas es
importante. Tendremos una fuerza ion dipolo más
fuerte si tenemos cargas más fuertes en los iones.
Así que, si en lugar de un sodio con una carga
positiva de 1 tuviéramos un ion calcio con una
carga positiva de 2, entonces los extremos
parcialmente negativos de las moléculas
de agua serían atraídos aún más, tendríamos
fuerzas ion dipolo más fuertes. Del mismo modo,
si hay momentos dipolares más fuertes, eso también
hará que las fuerzas ion dipolo sean más fuertes,
o viceversa, si tuviéramos una molécula con un
momento dipolar más débil no tendremos fuerzas
ion dipolo tan fuertes. Las fuerzas de Coulomb son
inversamente proporcionales a la distancia entre
las cargas, así que también vamos a tener
fuerzas ion dipolo más fuertes cuanto más
cerca estén estas cosas una de otra. Pero, hasta
cierto punto, eso ocurre en muchas de las fuerzas
intermoleculares de las que hemos hablado, porque
en cierto nivel todas son fuerzas de Coulomb.